au poste frontière de kieffer spelden
dans le sud est du pays
les entrées sont patiemment filtrés par
la police pour pouvoir passer la douane
il faut désormais remplir plusieurs
critères être allemand ou résidant en
allemagne mais surtout présenter un test
de dépistage du coc vite 19 récent est
négatif pour cette conductrice
autrichienne c'est la mauvaise surprise
je viens du tyrol je voulais seulement
traverser l'allemagne pour aller à
vienne
hier soir j'ai lu que l'on pouvait
transité par l'allemagne avec un test
négatif est vrai c'est une catastrophe
j'ai un chien qui a 15 ans dans la
voiture je vais devoir traverser
l'autriche pendant des heures je ne
connais pas le chemin et je n'ai pas de
gps
c'est super les frontaliers mais aussi
des professions considérées comme
stratégiques bénéficie cependant d'une
exception à condition toujours de
présenter un test pcr négatif de
nombreux automobilistes ont dû faire
demi tour
les personnes auxquelles l'entrée refusé
sont rassemblés avec leurs voitures
une voiture de police arrive devant le
convoi et ensemble ils prennent la route
pour retourner en autriche a offert un
ticket gauche pour restaurer le même
filtrage est effectuée à la frontière
avec la république tchèque
un millier de policiers sont mobilisés
pour assurer ces contrôles une décision
qui n'est pas du goût de l'union
européenne bruxelles redoutent le chacun
pour soi et une remise en cause de la
libre circulation dans l'espace schengen
mais pour l'allemagne qui pointe la
lenteur de la campagne de vaccination
coordonné par bruxelles
priorité est donnée à la sécurité et à
la protection de la population
je pense que nous avons besoin du
soutien de bruxelles maintenant en
particulier en ce qui concerne la
vaccination il y a beaucoup de travail à
faire bruxelles peut apporter une
contribution importante pour tout cela
ici à la frontière c'est ce que font la
police fédérale et celle du land
afin d'obtenir le même
résultat malgré des chiffres de
contamination en baisse en plus de ces
restrictions aux frontières
l'allemagne vient de décider de
maintenir au moins jusqu'au 7 mars
le confinement partielle de sa
population